[Musik]
der potsdamer platz heute uns in den
20er jahren damals war es der
verkehrsreichste platz europas
dann ein brachland menschenleer mitten
in der stadt
denn mit dem bau der mauer 1961 mit der
potsdamer platz teil des streng
bewachten todesstreifens die ersten
segmente werden zwei tage nach dem
mauerfall 1989 abgetragen die menschen
strömen durch die offene grenze
1994 beginnt der wiederaufbau der
potsdamer platz wird zur größten
baustelle europas
nach nur sechs jahren ist das projekt
weitgehend fertig vor allem hochhäuser
prägen die neue silhouette gebaut von
den star architekten helmut jahn hans
kollhoff und renzo piano
die riesige lücke im herzen der
hauptstadt ist geschlossen der potsdamer
platz zum symbol für das neue wieder
vereinte berlin
[Musik]
pflastersteine markieren den verlauf der
abgerissenen mauer wenige mauerteile
sind wieder aufgestellt dazu gibt es
schautafeln
[Musik]
bei den red bulls man müsste mehr davon
sehen gerade weil das so ein
historischer ort ist die mauerteile
finde ich gut aber man hätte hier die
geschichtliche bedeutung mehr
wertschätzen sollen hier gibt es sehr
interessante informationen
die sind schon sehr hilfreich für
besucher wie mich die noch nie in berlin
waren
glas stahl und beton er folgt auf platz
ist wieder ein pulsierendes zentrum dem
erlebt